wie bitte wie kann das sein das weltraum
teleskop der europäischen
weltraumagentur esa
das weltraumteleskop gaia hat jetzt
daten ermittelt die zeigen dass unsere
milchstraße eine galaxie aus zwei
galaxien ist denn unsere galaxie hat
eine ganz besondere eigenschaft und die
hat er jetzt ermittelt und das ergebnis
ist wirklich meint bleibt warum wir also
in zwei galaxien leben jetzt den clip
zum science fiction bei uns gibt es
täglich science videos abonniert den
kanal
denn nur dann verpasst ihr kein video
herzlich willkommen das ist eine
wirklich unglaubliche erkenntnis unserer
galaxie unsere milchstraße besteht aus
zwei galaxien und das hat die astronomie
jetzt wirklich überrascht bisher gegen
die forschung davon aus dass vielleicht
ein paar kleinere satellitengalaxien
also sehr kleine gebilde mit unserer
milchstraße verschmolzen sind
doch diese vermutung war ein irrtum
jetzt hat ein forschungsteam von der
universität groningen in den
niederlanden den beweis für einen
riesigen kosmischen crash gefunden rund
30.000 untersuchte sterne sind nämlich
ganz anders als alle anderen sterne in
der galaxie
sie bewegen sich entgegengesetzt zu
einem großen teil der sterne und auch
ihre chemische zusammensetzung ist
anders und das ist das wirklich irre
dran sie haben sehr ähnliche
eigenschaften und 13 kugelsternhaufen
mit den gleichen eigenschaften hat das
forschungsteam auch noch im halo der
milchstraße gefunden also dem riesigen
kugelförmigen bereich rund um die
scheibe unserer galaxie der schluss des
teams diese sterne und sternhaufen im
halo stammen alle aus der gleichen
galaxie und zwar nicht aus unserer
heimat galaxie amina helmi aus dem team
dazu wir haben im halo sterne von
verschmolzenen satellitengalaxien
erwartet was wir nicht erwartet haben
ist dass die meisten halos sterne
tatsächlich gemeinsam aus einer großen
verschmelzung stammen bisher war die
wissenschaft der festen überzeugung dass
sich dort draußen reste eben von
zwerggalaxien befinden würden aber dass
dort gleich eine ganze galaxie zu finden
ist darüber sind jetzt alle überrascht
das team hat weiter recherchiert
offenbar gab es vor zehn milliarden
jahren einen riesigen crash zwischen
unserer milchstraße und einer anderen
galaxie woraus sich dann unsere galaxie
in der heutigen bekannten form bildete
denn auch das konnte das forschungsteam
ermitteln die milchstraße ist nämlich
nicht überall eine dünne scheibe das ist
bekannt in der mitte ist sie zehn mal
dicker es war eher war allerdings völlig
unklar warum simulationsrechnungen des
teams zeigen jetzt dass dieser dicke
teil auch durch diesen crash wesentlich
mitverursacht worden ist und
wahrscheinlich erklärte auch das
mysteriöse flattern der galaxie
sie tut das nämlich in nord süd richtung
also senkrecht zu ihrer der drehachse
beziehungsweise parallel
bisher ging man davon aus dass der
durchgang kleinerer galaxien diese
bewegung ausgelöst hatte aber diese
bewegung werden nach den neuesten
erkenntnissen dann quasi das
nachschwingen dieses crashs damals
drangen die fremde galaxie dann von oben
oder von unten in die milchstraße 1
wollte sie erst in die eine richtung aus
durch gravitation wurde sie
zurückgezogen und wollte die galaxien
die andere richtung aus grund also für
den dickeren bereich in der mitte
unserer galaxie und dieses nachschwingen
das ist dann quasi der effekt den wir
mit dem flattern sehen allerdings ist
das noch reine spekulation es gibt noch
keine forschung dazu aber es ist ein
beeindruckend klares und ein leuchtendes
bild wir sind also gespannt was da noch
so alles herausfinden wird bei der
kartierung unserer galaxie aber das war
ja schon mal ein absoluter hammer
abonniert unbedingt unseren englischen
kanal das könnte hier tun sticks und
science fiction uhr verpasst ja dann nur
verpasst den gar nichts also garantiert
gar nicht denn dort gibt es genauso
videopremieren wie hier auf dem
deutschen kanal und da drunter geht es
weiter mit einem englischen wohl video
what is it before that big bang stay
tuned csu